on voit ça dans l'univers de la danse
mais plus contemporaine cette fois notre
rendez-vous junior est un spectacle pour
et avec des enfants mélanie poker nous a
rejoint pour nous présenter pop-up
garden bonjour qu'a menées le titre du
spectacle c'est bien paul gardanne
essais se déroulent en ce moment à la
ferme de bel ébat de guyancourt pendant
près d'une heure c'est un instant
poétique c'est un spectacle en hommage à
gilles clément impôts est paysagiste et
botaniste français mais aussi à tous
ceux qui créent des jardins à partir de
rien sont pas mes mots mais ceux de
david et venturini le directeur
artistique de la compagnie italienne et
tpe se pensent peut être trop basé sur
un petit écolo mais c'est surtout la
relation entre l'art et la nature entre
l art et les jardins notre jardin son
jardin artistique et même à même aussi
en jardin dans lesquels la relation avec
la nature
c'est plutôt en relation avec la
créativité
alors david et venturini parle d'un
jardin mais dans un jardin bien
particulier particulier parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'herbe pas d'eau pas de fleurs en
tout cas pas de manière réelle c'est un
spectacle interactif des capteurs
analyse les mouvements des danseurs et
du public et évolue avec eux et c'est un
spectacle très ludique de danseurs sont
sur scène et joue avec les éléments de
danseurs pros de danseurs professionnels
mais pas seulement vous le voyez sur les
images il y a des enfants ça arrive au
bout d'une quarantaine de minutes et une
quarantaine d'enfants d'enfants peut
aller alors s'amuser sur scène et faire
réagir les projections animées set mais
c'est un spectacle pour tous aussi
écouter bien
j'ai beaucoup aimé la fin la fin ces
termes qui peuvent bien méritée but
vous
à penser que c'est un peu nul est à vous
m et là moi qui s'était bien aimé bien
typés mais pour la fin un petit peu pas
et après apprécié mais tous après j'ai
fait une danse après qu apprécier mafia
sur mer au début je trouvais ça on va
dire un petit peu étrange et en fin de
compte ça s'est révélé super intéressant
je pense qu'ils ont réussi à bien me lis
qu'on n'entendait pas l'effet sonore et
l'effet visuel et la deuxième partie
était super recul pour les enfants alors
pour découvrir pop à gardonne via une
nouvelle représentation le samedi 17
décembre à 18 heures à la ferme de bel
ébat à ne pas manquer donc pour les
enfants qui ne veulent pas être
simplement spectateur mais aussi acteurs
le temps d'une pièce
merci beaucoup mélanie poquet